all right we're back what day is it
taste doesn't matter
anywhere to be the we got a movie from
so for the other day yeah yesterday
yesterday we watched it last night we're
gonna do a review on it should we say
what it is yeah glad it's psycho mania
psycho mania from 1973 British
motorcycle movie supernatural it was
good it was good yeah I liked it very
much I've actually heard of it but I'd
never seen it I heard of it because um
the Damned did a song called psycho
mania yeah and which I presumably is
based on that movie so I I knew of it
because of that but I had never got
around to seeing it I loved like British
movies from that time period because
some of the same actors were in like
[ __ ] blood on Satan's claw and
Witchfinder general and all this kind of
like I love all this British horror
movies from that time period yeah so if
you guys want to see that movie before
we review it and then you know we can
review it together then not be a time to
go see psycho mania yes she sent us like
a deluxe copy of it blu-ray had a little
booklet inside every be an and a CD and
a bunch of extras the making of it and
the people that were involved and it's a
motorcycle
it's a it it's a motorcycle gang movie
and about a motorcycle gang that learns
how to come back from the dead yeah it's
like a creepy motorcycle gang whoa
it wasn't like not like some of the
American ones like they did on MST like
sidehackers and wild rebels all I kinda
stuff which is just like you know teen
delinquency movies it's not really like
that no they they made the thing and
they kind of thought it would be
forgotten but it turned out to be kind
of like a classic yeah it was kind of
hilarious watching all that movie has
problems in it but they worked around
the problems yeah like shitty
motorcycles was the motorcycles they
thought they were gonna get you know
that kind of stuff but yeah it's good
movie yeah I liked it a lot actually so
I'm glad we actually got around to see
yeah so thanks so P percent of that
would say it's not gonna go up to the
review of it's not gonna go up tomorrow
it's gonna go up the following Friday
noka yeah cuz we already did the review
for this Friday um but we got new lights
we got the rest of ya we got two more
lights
that's kind of Redwyne like bouncing off
over there that's not good more pink
yeah and then I got another blue one
over there
yeah I might may have to turn that and
send her with a little bit more purple
yeah we're farting around with it I
figured out we just said okay like all
these little lights on the floor there
he just keep like moving a floodlight
stuff like that book he loves if she
comes in here and takes a bath in the
light yeah she's like so then yeah
sometimes if you see the show and you
see like little shadow that's covered in
lakes funny I look at you and your whole
side of your head is red here but when
you look in the camera it doesn't look
right yeah it's it's it's red is it yeah
but it doesn't show up on I can't read
my own face yes you know what I mean I
can see it like it look at look at that
look at the side of my arm no look it
look it okay yeah look it look to us it
looks totally red yeah we look like
we're in a dark room yeah but it doesn't
look like that on the camera yeah it
does it's it well that's why you have to
like dick around with this stuff with
like the camera on because it's like you
can't see like what it looks like looks
cool in the room but like when you get
it on a camera it doesn't like anything
that's in that back went off the shoe
haves see if we change code what it's
gonna go really dark in the cameras it
go out of focus let's see that's whoa
you guys like it was too dark it's too
dark I'm telling ya all right we could
do that for a Halloween show that way
these candles in it I need to get a we
need to dim that back one I think okay
well you mean you know it could be
bright and bright but not that bright
we need to dim that by about 25% I don't
even remember what wattage that bulb is
yeah that lamp is pink though it's like
it's this crazy like tulip shaped yeah
but it's like plastic pink on the
outside another flood might be good
there instead of that bouncing off that
wall well that's what I thought you were
gonna do with the set of two that I just
we can always get another one they're
not that expensive that's true yeah oh
also I wanted to think and I forgot to
do this and I feel really bad but we had
a couple of contributions for other
large contributions and I hope I'm
pronouncing this person's name right nil
a nily I don't know about it now yeah
it's like they sent me some too it was
funny because they sent me one like very
generous contribution every PayPal
like wow that's pretty cool and they'd
like later that day they set like
another that amount again and they were
like for good that's like that's pretty
awesome so yeah we'll have to whenever
we get our [ __ ] together and start doing
t-shirts and stuff like that again yeah
we'll have to
we'll send one out to you guys to that
that have sent us like PayPal donations
it's just that's like so hard to keep
track of and all our [ __ ] supplies
are running out yeah yeah well there's
stuff to make sure it's our kind is kind
of running out right now but we'll get
to it this is good this is almost over
at least here we actually probably have
to go to the store at some point today
it's like yeah it's a that's one of
those things it's like I [ __ ] buy I
have like you know how on Amazon you
have like those subscriptions like to
every like a month or two months or
whatever they send me like a big box of
like shampoo and [ __ ] soap and [ __ ]
like that I coulda sworn that I had one
for toothpaste or that I had bought like
a big [ __ ] ton you know like it's Sam's
or Costco have they other's big [ __ ]
things of like fifty bajillion boxes of
toothpaste I could have sworn that I
bought one of those last time I was at
Sam's and I don't I know we haven't used
that much toothpaste so it's the last
time I bought that but I guess it's not
around here did you check underneath all
the sakes yeah okay so I guess let's not
bother them about that we got to talk
about white just listen right there well
yeah but it's like not today because
I've been working on working on my book
and [ __ ] like that oh I put up the
witching hour today is actually both my
stories usually I do like kinda classic
stories or every now and that I do ones
from reddit or whatever but today we
were doing zombies so I said well hey I
have a couple of zombie stories and I
already had them recorded so I'll just
like throw them on there and hopefully
people will like him um you know they're
from two of my different books also I
was doing I was writing about a case
today I'm like working on a case right
now like for my faceless villain for
book listen to this weird [ __ ] this is
another one where there was a woman this
was in [ __ ] but [ __ ] Minnesota that's
not what the name of the town is but
it's like it less than a thousand people
it's just like a tiny tiny town this
happened in February it was minus
nineteen degrees and
that's Fahrenheit for all of you
Europeans so it's [ __ ] cold this poor
woman was working at a liquor store by
herself she closed up the store and
disappeared and then they found her body
six weeks later like off this really
remote road and the creepy thing I'm
like on reddit like on the unsolved
murders thing and some people that
actually live in this town or live close
to that town they're like you know
what's scary about this is that whoever
killed her had to have been from here
because one nobody drives through this
[ __ ] town at night cuz it's out in
the middle of nowhere they're like where
that road is where they dumped her body
that's like nobody knows about that road
except people that live around here so
they're like the creepy thing is that
everybody knows everybody in this town
because it's only like 900 something
people he's like so we try not to talk
about the murder too much because we
don't know if we're talking to the
person that did it right because they
still have a call they are this happened
in 2001 and they still haven't caught
the person that did it he's there and
why the [ __ ] would somebody go out when
it's minus 19 because these people that
are like that live there are like you
know the thing about it like living up
here and living you know it doesn't
usually get that cold but that night in
particular it was that cold and it was
like really windy and [ __ ] - yeah
they're like why would anybody go out on
purpose on that because - no - grant
well yeah but they said it must have
been you know that's another thing that
must have been somebody that worked I
mean somebody must have really really
wanted to commit a crime I don't know if
they wanted to kill her specifically or
they just wanted to kill somebody
somebody with military and law
enforcement background so some people
speculated that it because Leary top
right and the reason I'm saying this is
because in the military you learned the
best time you the best time - for any
kind of attack is during the shittiest
weather shitty weather because no one's
around and that's not how they say no
one was around not only that but limit
to the ability to respond yeah if
there's a bunch of snow that's the best
time because the cops you know the use
of the roads gets [ __ ] up and you
don't do it from a car you do it on foot
you know some are something they can
move through the snow it's tactics you
have to use the right tactics but
whoever it was he knew her I kind of
suspect as much - because they whoever
like all the people that were commenting
that lived around there they
like um yeah this liquor store that she
worked at was pretty much that and like
the American Legion Hall and like one
other bar that was all that was open at
this time of night American he's like a
10:00 p.m.
yeah it's a veteran from uh from there
it might matter they said in the 40 mile
radius it was only like a couple and
like maybe a gas station or two that's
all that was opened it's like everything
else when it's that cold closes at 7:00
p.m. nobody saw somebody he used a ruse
to get her into his cars and then he did
it because they found like the front
door and the liquors because she was
closing it up like I said the furniture
was a liquor store was locked the back
door was unlocked and her coat and purse
were still in there yeah so she must
have either just popped out to like warm
her car up because she was closing the
store or she popped out to take out the
garbage or something like that and
somebody like [ __ ] stabbed her just
somebody knew her
it had to be I mean why the [ __ ] would
some random [ __ ] would just be
water and through this Oh random dude
wouldn't have known she was even there
exactly and they wouldn't have to end
like I said everybody that investigated
this said that that road there like that
no locals like locals know about that
but nobody else nobody else what it's
like really hard to get onto it's like a
back road so yeah so I was writing about
that today so that's like pretty [ __ ]
creepy so if any of y'all are from
Minnesota and want to weigh in on that
it's near Brainerd I think I camera for
the name of the town is at Pine River
maybe something like that but it's like
a really really small town
yeah so that's but what I've been
working on this morning what do you been
doing this morning watching China
watching China yeah guys need to keep an
eye on China it's just not you know
China China United States are in a war
posture you know I don't think it's
gonna end up being a shooting war but I
think it's gonna end up being a cold war
and the other day you know I think he
was I forgot what his title was he was I
think it was like secretary is another
he was talking to China and gave an
address to the Chinese in in Chinese and
it was had to do with the history of
China and when you're giving somebody a
history lesson in their own language
that's not a good sign but you can go on
the White House website and go look at
that message
that they sent China and it's it's eerie
basically it says you know well it says
a lot of things a lot of things the kind
of what the intent was is that China is
not China real China is Taiwan and Hong
Kong that's [ __ ] basically what the
intent of the message was and when you
say [ __ ] like that to the Chinese to the
CCP that's fighting words because
because of mismanagement of the West and
China got [ __ ] over during the [ __ ]
media tearing a bunch of treaties and
stuff
China ended up splitting into a bunch of
different factions and one of them was
Taiwan and and and basically what the
speech said what in China hates Taiwan
it's on the island of Formosa basically
what this what them but the intent of
the speech was is that China's true
government is Taiwan alright you don't
say that to the CCP it's a they hate him
yeah all right yes so that's fighting
words but it was polite it wasn't really
to the Chinese government it was to the
Chinese civilians but we're see what
happens yeah I think it's gonna be a
cold war kind of like between the Soviet
Union the United States that's probably
why you kids you remember that yeah you
guys don't know anything about it but
you know I was everything well I'm sure
well a lot of the people that watch
watch us from the range yeah right y'all
remember that [ __ ] how to like hide into
your desks and [ __ ] like that at school
yeah
case you got blowed up or that you know
the the [ __ ] day we all came back to
school the after that [ __ ] what was
that nuclear holocaust TV movie the day
after yeah and like everybody came to
school the next end that's all they were
talking about yeah we're like freaking
out about it back then never happened
that happens happily but it's a very
it's a very powerful message on youtubes
on the White House they put it up
yesterday and
he's been thinking about it and you can
you can see it it's funny to see to see
a white guy speak Chinese fluently
I remember I was mentioned to you
yesterday yeah sounds like a Chinese
person talking you know you look miss
white guy Wow
well it's a language like any other
languages yeah I know but it's very rare
you see you see white guy [ __ ]
speaking it blew my mind
subtitled so you can understand what
he's saying and you know you make of it
what you will but I'm sure the Chinese
were not happy with that or the CCP
wasn't happy I think maybe some of the
Chinese people were happy with it we'll
see well as with everything we'll just
see how things play out which is nothing
my eyes can do no sure all right let's
call him to shut it down you want to
shut it down yeah you don't want to say
anything about pokey or anything no I'm
gonna talk about I mean I've already
talked about Pookie Pookie [ __ ] me up
this morning get up daddy
yeah just wake up wake up hates it when
I'm asleep well we went to that kind of
early lesson so from her perspective
she's probably like gotta jam in forever
you guys have been sleeping for days and
weeks and years yeah please get out and
play yeah yeah that's probably axis
shades what's up and then she runs yeah
yeah she's right here my head it's like
living with a little monkey yeah it's
not like it she's not like a cat
she's like a monkey she is like a tiny
Mike or like a human child that doesn't
talk kind of yeah and that's very very
very small yeah I'm very spoiled she is
but it's like what are you gonna do she
didn't speak kitty I mean she's a brat
sometimes but we love her she's adorable
even though she's always getting in
trouble alright so we'll talk to you
guys again tomorrow have a good rest of
the day